we should start by talking about what
David has brought oh yeah this is
different than a normal podcast yeah
yeah
yeah I bought a selection of my favorite
bowls which my wife makes
they're called mellows I've also brought
a bunch of flowers I figure we would be
able to smell a lot of different flowers
so you can get the the terpene profiles
I think it's kind of like when you do
wine tastings so I think that's
important I'm really into terpenes
I bought some body rub some oils that we
can talk about some live resin and also
a pre-roll and these are a lot of these
products are all available on the market
today it's about kind of showing you
kind of how the evolution of the the
consumer experience has been mm-hmm and
these are some of the I've got at the
green door which is right around the
corner yes this office this one of my
favorite shops to go to and do you
distribute any of these products yes so
northern emeralds has actually just
talking to Kody this morning about it
and we distribute would help with
northern emeralds distribution we share
an office with them actually over in
Oakland we've we've tried working with
Papua and Berkeley but I think they do
their own distribution so a lot of these
brands do their own kind of self
distribution but then often times a lot
of like smaller brands or boutique
brands will often ask a third-party
distributor to help out so that that'd
be us the interest yeah so since you
guys have gotten into yeah let's break
it apart some of these so this one is
called blueberry crumb I I got this
particularly because it just smelled
really good it has this like like really
sweet nose right yeah so that you'll get
this like crazy blueberry nest to it
this is a northern emeralds gelato
you're gonna get like kind of a cheesy
musky you know type of type of smell
there all right here we go there and
then this is the full Cana
yeah so this is more like the lemon
it's called orange zest mmm but you get
that like citrusy feel and like when you
smell flowers I have that citrus feel
you get way more of that uplifting
energizing head high head high really
yeah that signals what strain it is yeah
usually it's like sativas have more of
like a head high like citrusy lemony
kind of like a Roma to it and that's
kind of just like the the turkey and
profile which is basically just like
what you imagine is like a flavor
profile for wheat and then indica on the
other hand is more of like I think
people normally remember it by saying
like in the couch basically it's you
know you slip into the couch and you
just get really lazy okay it's more of
the body hi and yeah I think indica and
sativa are like the ways that people
typically like to categorize and like
hybrids but then at the end of day
there's so many different varieties of
strains that and nowadays with the
crossbreeding of all them everything
seems to be somewhat of a hybrid a
strain right yeah
and does the the strength of the smell
indicate its potency in any way or is
that just freshness not really I think
you so a lot of these have their THC
percentages now huh so if you look on
the labels you'll see how potent it is
all right this one says 27% no CBD this
one is your live resin this has 65
percent THC so it's gonna be way
stronger this is your ha ha and because
this is a resin you're gonna see like
you see all that's been extracted
control it this is like basically all
the trichomes have been put taking from
the flower all the cannabinoids are
extracted and put into this resin and so
this is what people use for dabbing yeah
yeah yeah
which is super strong right so pretty
strong how many milligrams of THC would
be in that so this is 650 milligrams
it's a lot yeah so I was like
concentrate yes super concentrate yeah
yeah
okay right and so for for the amateur
what do you guys recommend so like I
mean your flick 5 milligram edible is
that what you're talking yes so this is
the this is like that's 5 these are 5
those are 5 yeah so this is label Thanks
yeah there this is like brown butter
sage black sesame cookies and cream
right these are like gourmet low dose
and that that's cut what kind of the new
consumer is going after right they're
not trying to get blitzed on a dab
that's gonna get right but there are
consumers in those Instagram videos
though oh yeah I cannot compete yeah
there are people literally doing like 2
3 gram dabs full dabs and God and just
like holy cow valedale yeah yeah and
they're just like all right walk the dog
yeah but like for for what we're seeing
in the market new consumer you know
wants to do more micro dosing really
yeah so you know micro dosing I think
has revolutionized how I think about you
know cannabis consumption yeah right
because you know we never knew back in
the day what you were really getting
right you just like alright yeah just
show up at the story yeah right but now
you know the consumer can understand how
many milligrams it is smell the profile
understand what's within it and then
kind of build their relative scale on
how it affects them yeah and most people
you know when they get too paranoid or
they get a little bit like anxious yeah
they just did way too much right they
have to just they're just way sensitive
so dial it back keep dialing it back
until you can then add a little bit more
yeah right and how you feel what does
the market look like these days now are
more people buying edibles since its
become legalized in California well at
least from our standpoint as a
distributor the higher velocity items
and high volume items that flow through
the market are just like flour and
pre-rolls
still just because that's kind of the
most common like base of understanding
of what
it is okay and so people generally buy a
lot of you know these single pack
pre-rolls and it depends on the market
as well so if you're in the middle of a
city people will buy smaller quantities
just because there's a lot of tourists
and they like you know want to walk into
a dispensary these days when they come
visit San Francisco it's like part of
their to-do list yeah and then they'll
pick up something small versus like if
you're kind of this like brand loyalists
in like a more rural area you'll buy a
larger quantity like in denominators of
eighths or maybe even larger and then
edibles are a big part of as well and I
think it's typically for the kind of
newbie weed
I guess experiencer and they because
they for I guess for edibles the
argument for that eventually being a
bigger market is that you know for for
people who haven't consumed weed before
or smoked before they have to kind of
get their head around like two levels of
friction one is just like smoking first
anything and then second the weed part
vote for edibles they eat and anyway so
you know this is just like one step away
from consuming weed right yeah but
they're like very granular dosing yeah I
mean that was great for me when I
started getting into this stuff yeah but
I just find that it's a completely
different sensation anyway yeah yes yeah
yeah you're metabolizing in through your
liver it's more of a body hi you are
yeah the onset takes a little longer to
you have edibles you're looking at
typically an hour maybe an hour and a
half yeah there's some like beverages
like California dreamin which is a YC
batch they take theirs quicker yeah you
know so they're on sets quicker yeah the
the category that we see that's growing
pretty quickly is the concentrate market
but through vapes okay right so like
here here a couple examples
I brought some eras and then within each
one of these I have a different pod so I
carry around you know different pods for
different feelings this one is a
forbidden fruit so this is kind of like
an indica that's a little bit more of a
you know chilling out type of strain you
have the over here at ac/dc that's a
it's a CBD strain so when I'm not
looking to get really high but I'm
looking to you know take the edge off a
little bit that's why I really turn to
CBD often that's probably the cartridge
I switch out the most and then I have
this Nina Simone here which is uh or
sorry Nina Lamone which is a sativa and
this is from legion of bloom this is way
more when I just want a little kick up
and what's great about it is I can take
a little bit of a puff and I you know
doesn't smell it's discreet yeah and you
know I think that's what people are
looking for is that's kind of what
edibles do for people as well they can
just put it in their bag they can eat it
flower still has that smell I love it
yeah personally but there are people
that have that stigma attached to it to
have that you know oh I don't want small
likes dirty yeah my neighbors gonna find
out or my landlord yeah so it's um you
know I recommend if that's a thing you
can go the concentrates or find a vape
like a mighty from Storz and Bickel
where you can store it like you know new
a vape without combustion and it's not
that smelly and in terms of your market
your average customer for you guys in
particular mm-hmm
is it across the board growing is there
a certain segment where people are
really taking it up in terms of age or
demographic the fastest demographic
we're seeing in deck is actually the
baby boomers really yeah the they are
coming in and they are you know they're
replacing a lot of their prescription
drugs there's also this feeling of I
don't want to feel old
it's like a symbol of youth Yeah right
which is super ironic because this is
the generation that kind of brought us
the war on drugs supportive you know
this movement that and for us you know
dare they worked it there yeah all right
yeah work they pushed their right they
were like you know they were kind of
hippies or they knew about it but they
kind of bought into this war on drugs
mentality and it's you know funny ironic
that they're coming back to this you
know because of their health ailments
and you know
feelings of have changed which is good
right yes it positive direction and I
think there's this whole kind of like
like branding around like wellness as
well for for a weed not just the fact
that it gets you high but also there's
like CBD effects that kind of have
medicinal properties or just herbal like
its kind of seen as somewhat of like an
herbal remedy or you know something like
that that helps your general day-to-day
lifestyle can you break down CBD for
people who aren't yeah in the know yeah
so I think it stands for cannabidiol if
the I don't know how to actually set
cannabidiol in a bad I'll yeah and it
basically comes from you can actually
derive from two different plants like
marijuana and hemp and so the hemp base
CBD is legal and you can sell that
anywhere so you can get it like Costco
if you want I've seen like hemp lotion
and like all that sort of stuff but then
there's also just like CBD products that
are derived from marijuana that can be
sold in dispensaries and essentially
what it is is it's it's you know for for
I guess the layman it's its THC without
the effects of getting high and you know
have like medicinal properties that
essentially will reduce pain and it'll
basically generally make you feel a
little more chilled out and you know
otherwise you won't feel too much of an
effect of getting yeah high of THC okay
the the crazy thing about CBD is if you
look at you know if you watched that CNN
special weed from Sanjay Gupta he had a
few a few years ago but you know
essentially a CBD was really helpful for
people with epilepsy and you know that
had seizures so there's a group called
you know the Stanley Brothers out in
Colorado they were growing Charlotte's
Web and what's crazy is if you looked at
the the history of cannabis growing a
lot of it was bred for potency it was
also bred and for smell you know but
people didn't really understand the
science around what was in it and so
with a legalization of it with the
requirements of lab testing they started
finding other cannabinoids and CBD THC
or two of perhaps hundreds of
cannabinoids within the plant itself
so you're seeing research on THC VT
see a CBN CBG all these different
cannabinoids are helping people identify
ways to help them in their in their life
and with CBD especially if you just take
it from hemp derived the the problem is
there you don't have this what they call
the entourage effect and what what that
pretty much means is each of the
cannabinoids kind of help each other
with the fact and so that's why when you
look at something like Popham Barclays
like three to one yeah and you're
putting this on you know sore spots it
has a better effect than if you're just
gonna get a CBD lotion right you kind of
need one you know to balance to
complement each other yeah and like
products nowadays apart from just being
strain based as what you would normally
buy back in a day you're like I'll buy
some blue dream or some of this or and
based on strain now a lot of products
are ratio based or like effects based so
they'll have like higher THC content to
lower CBD or you know one to one or up
to ten to wash and that's just driven by
becoming more mass appeal right because
the customer goes in the store and
they're slightly dude I want to feel
this way like yeah I don't know all this
lingo
yeah or is that not true I think there's
I think the lexicon is is continuing to
build I mean a lot of people don't know
yeah and I think it's kind of like wine
yeah right where you have your
percentage of alcohol yeah but then you
have your tannins and kind of how you
know how it smells you know I think that
next frontier is really gonna be around
the terpenes right you're gonna have
your THC and CBD percentages yeah but
you know if you put this red Congo
against you know this lemon meringue the
smells are completely different and
you're gonna feel a little bit different
as well and you know that's just how
I've been human trialing myself stuff
like this like this rub how do you
derive the different strains or rather
the CBD for instance like how do you
pull the CBD out but not everything else
yeah so there's a number of extraction
methods now that's kind of bucket into
two categories you have solvent lists
and then you have solvent okay so
solvent list is kind of like with Mel
she uses actually this gold seal red
congolese through an ice water
extraction so it's basically you take
the flower and you trim you've run it
through cold water and ice and then you
sieve out the runoff into bags and those
bags produce hash you dry it out and you
have this hash that hasn't been you know
extracted with anything else but just
water and some some movement agitation
then you have you know co2 you have BHO
which is butane you have alcohol
distillation and so they put the flour
through there they actually rip apart
everything they take away the terpenes
they take away the cannabinoids and then
they reconstitute it at the end of it to
bring it back to to what it is right and
so when you look at something like a 3:1
CBD or THC CBD they most likely
extracted it probably co2 they were left
with different compounds then they
measured it see what the concentration
was and then they put it back to the
ratio that they wanted gosh okay now so
so is meadow making any product no okay
yeah so meadow meadow build software for
for dispensaries but we spend a lot of
time with our dispensaries understanding
the products understanding inventory
helping them with compliance and I think
everyone at Meadow is pretty passionate
about cannabis in general yeah so yeah
we're very much software-based and
working with a lot of people within the
supply chain okay in Vincents similarly
you guys are making anything your
distribution exactly so companies called
nabis and we basically do distribution
like license distribution so we'll
basically just move product at a
wholesale level in the supply chain okay
and what caused both of you to not get
into manufacturing with the actual like
higher level of the business that's a
good question I think for me at least it
was it's a pretty capital intensive side
of the supply chain just because you
need to buy all the equipment and
machinery and have the expertise to
produce everything yeah and that was not
something that I was born with or it
came with
and so you know a lot of people who do
manufacturing will essentially
white-label for a lot of other brands
and you know for us like we actually had
friends who were manufacturers who are
manufacturers rather and that's a lot of
the ways and how we kind of got
introduced to a lot of the brands that
we work with today yeah so it
distribution was a much lighter weight
kind of business for us to be able to
startup but you did fundraise right we
did fundraise we just closed a recent
round our seed round rats thanks yeah
and it was it was quite different it was
quite an ordeal
compared to tech or finance or any of
the traditional kind of VC fundraising
industries
just because we're licensed entity so we
have a distribution license in Oakland
it's a type 11 distribution license in
California okay and it kind of creates a
lot of friction as far as what investors
feel comfortable investing in meaning
you're gonna have to throw a bunch of
their cash at just getting a license
from the get-go yeah so that was
something we had to do it wasn't too
expensive it was several thousand bucks
to get the process done but you know on
the fundraising side it creates a lot of
friction just because for a lot of
institutions that can write larger check
sizes they have LPS for their funds that
basically they sign LP agreements that
say like you can't invest in certain
vice industries like gambling or alcohol
or weed of course with yeah right and it
was fund raising similarly difficult for
you guys for meadow yeah well we went
through YC right which i think is an
unfair advantage but we were the first
company to go through I didn't think
they were gonna accept us we had Kevin
Kevin Hale yeah sir and Carolyn I hope
Carolyn levy yeah so we're oh it was ten
ten minutes the most intense questioning
what did they ask you everything
I mean we talked about the legal side
yeah yeah we are an ancillary business
right and you know we chose that because
all of us have been in tech for a while
have been building software and we just
saw a need to build this the system that
allows dispensaries to be compliant but
also run their business effectively
I mean 90% of the shops are our
mom-and-pop right now in California so
and they don't you know if you've looked
at prop 215 and where cannabis was
records work I considered evidence so
people didn't really keep keep records
yeah you know heavy records that's why
you hear about companies it's all cash
oh gosh
all records and coming into legalization
yeah now you have to keep records for up
to seven years you have to keep attacker
tax records you have to keep patient
records you have to keep you know
everything from who's bringing in the
product to touching it to how it's
getting destroyed and everything and
then on top of that you have to create a
consumer experience that obfuscates all
the complexity around supply chain yeah
and so this consumer land already get a
lot of stuff it's more expensive than it
was which is definitely a negative but
you know you get a lot of selection you
get testing all that stuff so we just
saw a need for it early in 2014
yeah and when we apply to YC you know we
ended up getting accepted and
fortunately as this stuff was happening
in Colorado there are a lot of signs in
other states legalizing as well I mean
in California hopefully was gonna go we
don't know we saw all their attempts
that failed before and then we did a
pitch during demo day that tried to
bifurcate the the audience as much as
possible and so that way if they were
interested in weed or cannabis they
would come talk to us so what did you
what did you say yeah we you know a lot
of it was like hey if you want to stand
around the stand on the right side of
history come talk to us we really did
that so I think there was this feeling
of okay
like you have to kind of step forward
with us in order to make sense and so
you know when we did that we got a bunch
of interest did you have a both of you
guys did you have a lot of funds or were
they angels that could just spend their
own money on whatever they wanted for us
it was about half half like in terms of
capital committed like we we do have a
lot of smaller Czech angels just because
they're the types of people that David
just mentioned you are like
forward-thinking and they think this is
kind of like the end of Prohibition era
the New Age for weed and they're super
interested a lot of family offices and
then a couple of institutions here and
there okay yeah yeah and you we had over
40 angels right how much money did you
raise we raised two and a half on twelve
and so we came out of YC it took you
know we didn't close it up all after
demo day I took probably around nine
months well you know just meeting with
people and we just had like a rolling
close already saves all on save okay
and also it was a there it's not like
hey we're building you know XYZ CRM and
we're good to go
I think people had to get really
comfortable with the context around
cannabis first yeah and so there's a lot
of meetings that were just like
introductory here's what's going on the
space this is where we see the world and
then they had to kind of take that in
and like all right do I believe this and
if so let's have another meeting and
then we kind of work through yeah it is
a lot of that I feel like angels are
generally curious I think investors see
prophets and they see upside of all this
but then at the end of day like a lot of
them are doing their diligence as well
so they like come talk to weed founders
who are you know set as you know working
in the space and they ask them a bunch
of questions about like the regulations
the licensing how we view this industry
moving and shifting forward and then you
know they go back to their homework talk
to some other cannabis people and then
finally come back to a decision is there
one particular stat where you're just
like you tell it to the average
investment like oh my god you know like
how fast the industry is growing for
example like I don't even know like I
know it's popular you
have no idea how much weed people are
buying yeah I mean for us we kind of say
it's the end of prohibition in
California and I don't know if this is
the case anymore but a couple years ago
including the black market 80% of the
cannabis in the United States came out
of California so that was for us a great
pitch because we were based in
distributing California and are you wait
are you guys distributing out-of-state
no no no not legally no not at all yeah
but if you look at kind of where
agriculture is in California right you
know most of our products are exported
to the rest of the country right yeah
you know 70% of Agriculture comes out of
California right you know tech comes out
of California Coulter hands out for the
fifth largest economy in the world
right yeah and so I think there's a lot
that we have here especially because
cannabis the medical cannabis movement
started in San Francisco in 96 with prop
215 mm-hmm so there's there's just a lot
of history here I think um you know you
know as we're turning this thing over
there's just a hope that we keep a bit
of the culture and kind of what this
thing minutes what's hard I mean it's
hard I think this shit's amazing yeah I
love the truck I love you I'm not a
choice I get when I go to the store yeah
but um one thing I've been curious about
since the I mean legalization but before
that when I just had a medical card why
is there not like Marlboro why is there
not like one dominant edible company I
mean you said like all these stores or
mom-and-pop shops why is it not like you
know the CVS of canvas yeah I mean I
guess like for in terms of like brands I
think it's still so it's still fairly
like fragmented there are certain
companies that are getting bigger and
distributing a lot of products across
California but yeah none are I guess
fairly dominant not our dominant in
multiple states and I think that's
probably a lot of the reason why you
don't have like a Budweiser of wheat
even in California yeah like why I don't
get it like why isn't there just one
place
yeah I think there's a lot of
fragmentation in the market and if you
look at kind of how legalization has
started in 2018 the entire supply chain
has been reconfigured from what it was
before in the you know pre 2018 a grower
can go directly to a dispensary not have
a lab tested not have to go through a
distributor right but now with all the
different licenses a grower has to you
know cut their harvest give it to a
manufacturer the manufacturer that
brings it or the manufacturer has a
product ready for the distributor that
you pick it up yeah
the distribute then has a quarantine and
the yeah has tested and I'm Aptos for
what just the compliance testing so
making sure like homogeneity potency any
sort of additives like all that checks
out pesticides bacterial yeah you know
anything like that and then once it's
tested or approved then you know the
distributor brings it to the
dispensaries okay yeah and you know the
the problem that we're seeing in
California you know we thought this was
gonna be a bumper year harvest year
right jack we expected this to be
multiples bigger than for context this
was the first legal year first legal
year but last year we probably did three
billion dollars in medical sales this
year we'll probably do as much of that
in adult youth sales and medical will be
a fraction of that maybe you know half a
billion we get there and so the problem
is you have thirty three percent of the
state that's some form of local laws and
then 67% of the state that has no laws
whatsoever and because of that you have
this disconnect between state law where
you can get your permits but you can't
get a permit unless you get your local
permit and so it's a for the this legal
world that we're in it's not just the
compliance side but there's a lot of
advocacy and legal work on the
regulatory side on getting local
approval a local and novice to grow or
so ro to do anything to get touches
tribution anything yeah so imagine so
you're saying why isn't there this one
you know huge brand
it's because there's so many hoops to
jump through yeah there's and the
state's massive yes it is massive
this is not like Oregon right yeah it's
just a massive State and then you have a
disconnect between areas have licenses
areas that don't right and then people
trying to get licenses in these areas
but running throttle because of local
governments that haven't created those
laws hmm yeah and is the same thing as
German Colorado and the other i mean who
assume california's two biggest state in
terms of volume yes sales for sure and
then following that is Colorado or yeah
you have Colorado
you've Oregon Nevada is pretty Nevada
yeah and there's a very big yeah yeah
okay and then Canada
what's Janet's coming just federally
legalized so I think October 17th was it
the date that come they're basically
they passed the bill and now it's gonna
be fully enacted to be legalized across
the country really yeah so that can make
a huge play yeah yeah if there is a huge
bet yeah I mean I don't know I think if
you ask a lot of people in California
cannabis like if they can name all these
provinces a year and a half ago I'm
probably like no yeah but now you know
with Toronto like Toronto's coming up
you have Vancouver coming up you have
basically these companies that were
privatized with the government yeah and
now they're opening it up with into
public markets
yeah and now these huge massive Canadian
companies yeah listed yeah got all this
capital yeah and now they're investing
it into you know their own operations
but now bringing that capital down into
legal states like California yeah ya
know we've seen a lot of that as well I
think part of the whole like
consolidation pattern that will come
just because the markets so fragmented
right now will be heavily pressurized by
Canadian like publicly traded heavily
capitalized companies just because
they're coming in and they're buying up
pieces of licensed businesses in
California and other states in the
United States just so that they can have
their stay
in the ground for the future yeah and so
that's just to you know go back to why
isn't there this massive brand it's
because there's no capital - right not
only do you have all these hoops to jump
through on the regulatory side but there
isn't there are there's not banking yeah
yeah right because the FDIC obviously
federal federal right yeah and it is not
federally legal so what do people do for
banking yeah well it's kind of like a
band-aid solution for everyone I would
say there's like small like credit
unions that will bank cannabis companies
there's other banks some people just use
you know big banks but then they don't
mention anything and generally people
have four license businesses at least
they have multitude of banks and they
spread their cash across everywhere
because you touched on it earlier more
than I would say for us at least more
than 90 percent of our transactions are
in cold hard cash and so we have safes
everywhere as well as a banking solution
and how do you guys get it if you're
doing delivery well so we work with the
dispensaries that do the deliveries
these delivery operators collect cash on
site
so you place the order they come to you
they you know give you the order you
give them the cash a check your ID make
sure things you know on the up-and-up
and then they take that cash bring it
back to the dispensary and then and
that's it and they just kind of go back
and forth right it's not it's not like
they're it's not like an ice cream truck
well it's so well that's what's really
interesting now it is allowed for the
ice cream truck model coming into 2018
it was a hub-and-spoke model okay and
and now we're actually in the proposed
we've had three different sets of
regulations this year mm-hmm okay this
in there this year yeah and then this
the proposed regulation we've been in
what we call emergency regulations land
okay and then we have the proposed
regulations that should be coming out in
the next few weeks and in that this
iteration there was a proposed reg on
allowing delivery operators to deliver
anywhere into the state even in
prohibited areas which is in contention
with the Chiefs of Police Liga cities
that California definitely pride itself
on local control so if that does open up
you'll have ice cream truck model or the
taco truck model one that can carry up
to ten thousand dollars worth of product
at any time to deliver anywhere across
the state how much do you guys carry in
terms of like where how much we store in
our locations so we have two we have an
Oakland location we have an LA location
yeah and probably at any given point
overnight there's probably about half a
million dollars worth of product in
there and then flow through there's just
millions a week a product that doesn't
sit there just kind of you know hits the
inventory and then the next day it will
go out or something like that so typical
all shapes and sizes so a lot of it will
come in package final packaged goods and
then oftentimes it'll just come in big
just like gigantic trash bags full of 20
pounds of just raw ingredient raw
material flower base seriously yeah what
yes never so are you guys packaging and
the dispensaries we don't do packaging
it's there's these there's co-packers in
the industry or manufacturers who can do
the packaging but for us we we basically
just take final packaged goods and
deliver it to retailers that's our main
business but as far as the licensing
roles and responsibilities goes no one
can move product between two different
licensed entities without a distributor
so even if you're just like a farm
moving your product to a manufacturer
you have to contract out a distributor
or get your own distributors license in
order to move it and the reason behind
that is because I think the the state
government wanted to hold one license
party accountable for all things like
tax and legal compliance to which the
distributor's were kind of a gatekeepers
for all of these all these products
before it hits the retailer shelves yeah
and so we have to be in charge for like
compliance testing and making sure that
passes excise tax collection cultivation
tax collection permitting that to the
state so it's not just like money that
we have to remit back
the brand it's also money that we had to
remit to the government so we are kind
of just this like hub of the supply
chain that all product has to funnel
through before it reaches a consumer
okay so in on that tax side I'm curious
because what is the what's the rate 20
something percent the cultivation tax is
per per pound no either trim or full
flower and that's a you know 275 or 925
right so yeah something like that yeah
it's basically 150 bucks per pound
around that and then the excise tax is
15% on the wholesale value mm-hmm and so
the the and that's also taxed again at
the retail level yeah so your sales tax
taxes the sales the excise tax yeah and
all the products now there's taxes
everywhere and that's why the prices are
or yeah right and for the most part that
up site is for the government like are
they are the farmers are anymore no no
no no everyone that I mean that's why
these products are just so expensive is
because it has to be baked into that I
mean we we recently learned so like if
you wanted to the City of Oakland passed
these just city tax laws that are five
percent of gross receipts of sales so
it's not just like 5% of your margin
it's like of gross receipts so if you
buy it at a dollar and sell it at a
dollar you're technically just making
nothing but then because the gross
receipts a dollar you have to give five
cents to the government yeah on this
stuff cuz like the value is still so
high yeah you know like I mean when I
used to buy a 300 milligram bag I was
like of gummies that would last me
forever
yeah I'm not eating 30 milligram gummies
no just no no pass out fine or whatever
but now it's like I think twenty eight
dollars for a hundred milligram bag yeah
yeah do you guys sense that there's a
lot of price sensitivity absolutely okay
I mean I think that's why you know I was
looting too with the medical market
being you know pretty much decimated no
the the irony of legalization is that
there's a lot of medical patients have
gone and turned to the illicit market
for their
products right right you know the people
that are medical they're not you know
they need it as medicine they're not
there yet they want higher dosage they
want more value yeah and you know
because they're eating it every day or
every week to sustain their daily life
but because of the the imbalance of
prices on the legal market versus
illicit a lot of medical people have
turned to the illicit gone back you know
yeah no it's not crazy
yeah the state didn't see that coming I
think they did like I mean they didn't
the point of having a card anymore there
isn't really yeah except for you know
higher carrying limits or you want to
consult with a doctor that really wants
to kind of give you a treatment plan
yeah but for most yeah yeah I'd say for
most purposes it's the same products
they get sold recreationally as they do
medicinally right yeah
yeah because they were it yeah yeah it's
it's pretty complicated there was a dual
supply chain in the beginning of the
year an adult use in medical supply
chain so if you were a producer and you
were producing medical products you
could only sell to medical people and
vice versa I know nice and then they
combined it and now you have people that
are like right well there's probably
gonna be more throughput on adult use so
I'm gonna create more product there yeah
yeah but you know in order to get your
recommend if you get that then you can
get your tax your sales tax exempt so
but it's like 150 bucks to get it it
takes a few weeks to you know a couple
months to get yeah and then once you get
it you know expires in a year yeah dude
I haven't it was like what's the upside
yeah yeah it I save like two or three
dollars or something yeah consuming it
that if you spend you know a couple
grand a year on medicine
then yeah makes sense but you know I
think in the today's society it's really
tough to kind of make someone jump
through all the hoops to get it yeah
yeah but the the the problem is it just
it became it came down I think revenue
tax revenue for the government and
unfortunately I think the the community
that needed it at most on the medical
side or the ones are the most
disenfranchised from the whole process
mm-hmm do you find that um people are
very brand loyal or do they just shop
around and not care um I think people
are pretty open to right there there is
definitely brand loyalty like pop um
Berkeley makes these great topicals and
oils and things like that and then
there's certain like high-end brands
like dosis that makes these like really
great disposable vape pens that people
love buying yeah and and I but then I
think there is a large part of it that
people are just trying out new products
as well and they listen to what their
budtender says about them but tender
being like bartender but for weed and
oftentimes a brand will go and the way
that the budtender learns about all
these products is brands for as part of
their marketing they'll go into
dispensaries and do demos for these bud
tenders and they'll just pitch them on
things so whoever has the higher
marketing budget will go in and just buy
out shelves for the dispenser like shelf
space as a dispensary and they'll teach
all the bud tenders at you know all the
major locations and that's what will get
pushed through the most and I need to
get some recommendations from you guys
cuz like the people that I talk to when
I go to the store I think they're
sampling a little too much they're also
thing that there's there's been some
pretty I call apocalyptic events this
year where there's brands that have just
been wiped off because of the the
regulatory side so people that are used
to getting a specific brand aren't
getting it anymore
I think July 1 was probably the biggest
thing that we saw yeah so so July 1 was
when they implemented phase 2 testing
which essentially was around pesticides
and potency and then people that
couldn't pass it
essentially were DQ'd from the market
yeah it was
pretty bad it was insane there's videos
well because for compliance you have to
record yourself disposing of the product
whether you burn it or smash it or
whatever there's videos of dispensaries
just like as evidence just like damaging
all their products and just basically
having this huge demolition day of like
millions of dollars worth of product ya
know a lot of a lot there was a huge
shortage of supply in the market and
like my it's interesting my phone number
is listed on our license publicly so I
kept getting called for like Phase two
compliant product and I was like I mean
this is a huge opportunity for us it's a
distributor so let's go buy as much as
we can
yeah but yeah generally speaking there
was a huge shortage in market Wow so
brands are coming and going it's it's
almost as brand rush that we're seeing
people are trying to create these
different brands you try to get into
different consumers but the market isn't
that sophisticated yet we're and I'm
talking about the supply chain where you
have people that do Co packing a co
manufacturing or like create this stuff
this IP yeah and then oftentimes if you
don't have a license you're kind of
you're at the whims of you know people
that do yeah and it's really tough from
a business plan model to to have someone
invest in you if you're just you know a
brand yeah so where do you guys see the
market going then like we have all this
regulation coming out like seems like a
bunch of random question marks but
obviously you're raising money you're in
this business like what does it look
like in five to ten years I think at
least from where we're sitting it's I
think it'll probably be another a few
years before anything federally changes
and more and more States will continue
to pass favorable regulations towards
cannabis so a lot of them will start out
by decriminalizing it and then making it
medicinally available and then
eventually recreationally available and
then once enough states kind of ratify
those laws then I think then the federal
government will eventually see a more
favorable light as well as far as the
legal side of things and but until then
the way we have to expand is although
we're currently in California we
actually have to set up a different
legal entity in each state so that we
segregated out our
business it's not interstate commerce
and you know basically expand that way
from state to state and then have like a
holding company that manages every other
child company so it's there's there's a
huge just cost of upkeep of your
business as well on like a legal
compliance standpoint security and it's
just like licensing and everything that
currently it's it's hard to build a
business in this in this industry
because there's also a shortage of
capital - mm-hmm mm-hmm
have you thought about getting capital
from any of these Canadian companies
investing in yeah they are I think
they're more so seeing all the players
right now as like pretty young so they
want to just like buy out companies here
and there for their licenses so they we
have seen some distribution companies at
least get bought out by Canadian
companies and I think it's hugely just
like like stock packages and like the
the sea levels we'll go join the company
and then the rest of the company kind of
gets let go and so it's it's been it's
been kind of this like brutal M&A like
climate right now yeah but it does
provide a lot a lot of opportunity for
you know small guys like us who can stay
afloat yeah and how about you David what
do you think the markets gonna look like
yeah I mean I think in California in
five years we're heading what 2023 there
is something that happens in 2023 with
the laws that allow that removes a
one-acre cap you know right now if
you're growing you have a one acre cap
that you can grow in however people have
doing stacking so they get a bunch of
licenses to stack but once 2023 hits
unlimited size grows can happen in
California
sure and so you know I think the small
farmer is is going to be in a tough
position when that comes out and so
they're they're gonna have to really
think about their genetics their terroir
where they're growing communicate value
to the consumer that's buying from a
small grower who puts a lot of love and
attention and sustainable growing
practices that the consumer can can buy
instead of just these monolithic big
crops now in five years I think I
personally would love to see the entire
country being legalized I know we're
meadow
you know we build we our goals to build
the best software for the industry yeah
but more than that it's about access for
everybody mm-hmm that needs it you know
even if you're a kid with epilepsy you
should be able to get your CBD oil in
school to minister by a nurse if you
need it the I think the things that were
at odds with right now is we're such a
young industry that is standing on the
foundation of advocacy all right this
was all about advocacy and patient
rights and access and you know
legalization to some extent but it's
like now with this industry model you
have the capitalization side and with
such a small industry that's essentially
ceding a lot of ownership to you know
the capital markets through either
Canadian companies or other bigger
companies that are shell for other
bigger companies you're at odds you're
playing a game that you're already kind
of at a disadvantage from from
especially from the og people I think
it's going to be really important that
people band together in order to kind of
move forward but you're already seeing
alcohol move in with their investment
and consolation you have rumors with
coca-cola doing a CBD drink beverage
right you have constellation yep yeah so
you have a little bit they are the guys
behind Corona oh all right drinks all
pharma you're gonna see tobacco you know
these are huge players that are seeing
their market shares change because of of
cannabis yeah and so I think you're
gonna see a lot more M&A activity you
may even see it's feeling very frothy
right now look
the Canadian markets but there's because
there's only so limited access to invest
that capital yel keeps coming if they're
it very much feels like internet.com
like bubble is getting created yeah and
sure there's going to be a handful
winners but my fear is that there's me a
lot of people that are just out of the
game yeah and then we're left with you
know less election we're left with less
operators that have built this you know
industry and this movement mm-hmm I
think you're also gonna see a lot more
exporting globally you're always seeing
contracts being made with Canada and
other countries I think you're gonna see
a rise in Spain and Germany they're
gonna be coming out and being bigger
players but yeah cuz I don't know like
internationally in Europe for instance
you know if you buy cannabis somewhere
where where are they growing like is
that coming from California somehow
how's that working yeah yeah I don't
actually know how where they get it from
it must grow it locally
I'd imagine or bring it in from
somewhere in South America I think that
there there's a huge grow a lot of grow
ops down there Canada - yeah huh-huh
yeah it's interesting when you're
talking about the adverse advocacy said
I have have things like High Times and
like you know Cheech and Chong mm-hmm
have they been more harmful or
beneficial for the industry hmm I think
on a raising awareness level it's been
beneficial yeah although sometimes the
messaging isn't quite the the level that
we needed to be because a lot of times
just like funny memes or like some you
know joke about yes like your friends
getting high but I think it I guess you
know to a certain extent it's a strategy
to raise awareness as well because that
is what captures eyeballs yeah and and
then you know High Times does provide a
lot of just like newsworthy articles
about cannabis as well so I think
there's there's kind of a lot of shift
in media foot focus as well for high
times and like
Co and all these sorts of like cannabis
media companies yeah I mean they're
they're definitely they're pioneers in
this and getting the message out you
know I mean you know it's hard to
imagine the fear that people had and the
stigma that surrounded this yeah 10 20
years ago yeah when they're still
publishing articles around home grows
and Cheech and Chong coming out smoking
a fat one well in public yeah
it's these are people that have helped
push this thing with a segment of the
market that could gravitate toward it I
think the problem was there are a lot of
people outside that didn't necessarily
want to affiliate with that you know
segment of the population and became
more stigmatized or more stereotypical
as a STONER yeah but as we've been
moving forward you know you the biggest
news that we saw in the last month was
Elon Musk taking a puff of one right and
it's so it's starting to change you have
one of Paltrow like looking at stuff you
have Oh Whoopi Goldberg
you know partnered with Maya on on stuff
so the the figures that are stepping
forward to represent cannabis are
changing or adding to this this movement
and getting people more comfortable with
it yeah but it's stigmas still pretty
high I just find it so silly man cuz
yeah because I mean I remember I grew up
in Massachusetts so like it was not
legalized when I was in high school so
you know you existed around all of that
but you know obviously you knew people
that were smoking when yeah like this is
like such a crazy mismatch of media and
reality yeah and now I I find it
happening all over again with
psychedelics yeah yeah
and that's why that Michael Pollan's
book was so great yeah yeah because it
was just like accessible and he's like
kind of nerdy and skeptical
yeah and boy oh it's not just you know
acid trips yeah
and that's what I've been following so
closely yeah to see the studies and if
it's gonna happen or not yeah yeah yeah
I was gonna say that and the media plays
like a huge part in that and I think
it's really hard at least for businesses
in our industry to get the word out
because normal channels like Google
AdWords or like Facebook ad marketing
and you know obvious like typical
channels you would use to get your name
or advertising out they'll shut you down
if you try to advertise that you're
selling weed and so yeah yeah so how do
you grow influencer marketing so like
basically having celebrities or like
people endorse your products and going
on you know kind of like newsworthy
sources and outlets that those are like
the hot times those are ways to get your
name out there yeah I mean I think that
like when you look at the the
psychedelic movement yeah it it's
following the the medical piece which
that's how cannabis star with prop 215
essentially what started with was the
HIV community here in San Francisco that
you know found relief in cannabis and
this you know we call them the the fairy
godfather
Dennis Peron who recently passed away
but he authored prop 215 which allowed
medical collectives to grow cannabis and
share with one another and you know with
medical that provided that that tip of
the spear for people to then you know
get in and then you know people with HIV
finally found a little bit more relief
and then other groups and other medical
conditions happen without so Hep C yes
exactly and then we look at the the
trials are going through with MDMA and
it's really around PTSD and for veterans
for people that are trying to come over
some psychological trauma they're having
guided sessions and having a way to rise
above what their their current state of
consciousness is you know and I think
you know my opinion a lot of this
especially for cannabis it's like grown
earth common biological place like a
biological plant it's almost like it to
me it's a human right to have this all
right
it's comforts from the right yeah it's
not like someone you know made this and
you know but I think what's crazy
especially in the world we live in with
so much hyper connectivity so much dress
and like all the day to day we need to
find outlets to go inward a little bit
more because there's just so much
stimulation outside and you know one of
the reasons I love cannabis is that
allows you to kind of have that and then
you know on the the site that's like a
del excite you know it's another
leveling up and a whole other sense of
awareness of yourself and and how you
interact with the environment around you
yeah yes that's fantastic I mean it's so
cool that people are are now finally
able to experience it in a safe way
yeah and in a dosed way do which doesn't
really exist with psychedelics yet
imagine in our lifetime
yeah it's gonna be a thing yeah
definitely yeah I don't know who's the
bleeding edge on this site it might even
be in the states it seems like most of
the funding and the studies are
happening here maps is a really good
organization to follow they're the ones
that are really pushing the the trials
and they're you know if there's people
that want to fund the movement for
psychedelics maps there's a great
organization to do that cool right on so
on the legal side I've been really
intrigued by people being exonerated
yeah it's huge yeah it's amazing so
what's like what's going on with that in
California have you been following that
part yeah yeah for sure I mean what's
been great with legalization is that
people aren't necessarily going to jail
anymore yeah for kit for cannabis
possession right and another thing
that's great is there's a lot of cities
that had stacks and stacks of medical
cannabis convictions that were coming
and just you know toss them all out yeah
San Francisco did it there's a lot of
other states or cities are doing it I
think what you also are finding that
people are realizing that with the war
on drugs with people that have been
more disenfranchised people of color in
different communities there's a sense of
trying to give back with social equity
programs and so not only is there a
decriminalization but there's a there's
a there's a movement on create an
on-ramp for people to get into the
industry yeah
I mean for us we actually have a social
equity partner for our license and what
that means is it basically just
incentivizes us to help incubate if you
will like a smaller like cannabis
business that's run by a business owner
who's been formally convicted of a
cannabis crime or like lives in a
certain area that is has been
disenfranchised due to cannabis crime
activity and so for us like we basically
contribute to a thousand square foot of
rent for each month to one of these
social equity partners and that actually
expedited our licensing process earlier
this year so the government actually is
creating ways to incentivize like
businesses to help other businesses that
are run by these disenfranchised folks
in the past to help them get their
operations up and running man it's so
awesome yeah yeah there's definitely a
lot more work that needs to be done like
well there's a lot of that's funding
right and so Senator Bradford just had a
b12 94 pass or SB I think 12 12 94 pass
which is a 10 million dollar fund which
will be given to different social equity
programs to help jumpstart their
business you know the the issue that we
still have is people you know you might
have resources in rent but you still
need capital and know how the kind of
right kind of run yeah and you know we
are there's still a lot more that needs
to be done in order to help you know
this group to move forward in this
industry especially as other in other
players and the and this game board have
been leveling up and yeah right well
that was kind of a narrative right so
you're just like you know all these all
these people who have been put in prison
for years yeah jail whatever no and then
like a bunch of white kids come in yeah
yeah that's legal now cool and they just
win the game yeah
Yeah right and so yeah I mean I don't
know the legal situation as well as you
do but it seems like that is not figured
out yeah no no not at all it's not yeah
I mean because you obviously like you
applied twice see you get some money and
they are racist right yeah but it you
know you don't have incubators like YC
really you have you know the hood
incubator you have supernovae you know
hook appears based in Oakland their
incubator bringing some some companies
in but they don't necessary have
millions and millions of dollars in the
bank they need to fund people yeah and
then you have you know groups in
different cities that don't have
unification around their programs either
right
but there's some interesting things
happening within San Francisco you're
gonna need to hire 30% of your workforce
from social equity people you also as a
dispensary may need to have a certain
amount or certain percentage of your
shelf space of products created and
manufactured by people from social
equity programs so there's there's
definitely still a lot of thinking
around that needs to happen but people
are trying and I think the the key and
all of this is for the consumer to
really recognize that when they're
buying you know one of these or like
even flow kana flow kana supports
artisans small growers up in Mendocino
and the Humboldt and Trinity's Emerald
triangle so when you're buying flow kana
you're supporting a small grower and
that's why I think more not just the
knowledge of how distinguish what is in
cannabis and how it makes you feel but
who made it why it was made where it's
coming from all those pieces need to be
connected for the value proposition why
someone to pay you know X dollars more
for this versus that right um just kind
of start a few questions or they're
there I mean cuz you've both done my say
you you didn't go through IC with your
current company now would this happen e
sure where there are certain elements of
like a canonical startup advice that you
found didn't always apply in the
cannabis industry uh or do you just
apply like the learnings and I mean I
guess a lot of it did apply like I
remember
definitely the hole I'd do things that
don't scale thing I we first started
this we had a friend who basically ran
like a pre-roll company that was
distributing across California and prior
to regulation this year is very much
just like a backpacking industry where
people would deliver their own products
to fulfill to retailers and so what me
and you know my best friend June did was
we just drove our like hundreds of
thousands of dollars worth of product in
the back of our cars across California
from like Oakland to Palm Springs and it
was it was pretty romantic in a way but
yeah I mean it like part of doing things
that don't scale like that kind of
helped us learn a lot about the industry
how products were being moved and like
just meeting people throughout the
industry as well so yeah I think a lot
of it does apply oh absolutely yeah I
mean I think we probably ever eWEEK
there's some mantra that we're quoting
either you know make something people
want or do things that don't scale is
great yeah yeah we often think a lot
about resilience right that cockroach
yeah and you know survive and thrive
mentality I think one of the biggest
things have helped us just to be a
little bit more patient about even with
all this activities you know don't worry
about competition right competition will
kill itself you're just focus on your
team focus on making something that
people want focus on talking to your
customers you know but one thing I think
that I've also taken an extrapolated
it's like build a community right right
one thing I love about YC is the
community of entrepreneurs and the
shared you know alignment on how to
build something and I think that's you
know why we're together yeah but you
know to take that sense of community and
kind of bring that within cannabis a
little bit more yeah because there's
just there's so much going on and then
finding people that are aligned and kind
of can move forward and take care of
their lane you know it's super important
yeah
yeah totally yeah the advice has been
great I highly recommend anyone that's
thinking about building a business to
look at YC especially for that advice
and look at you know the videos or any
of the podcast yeah there's so much you
know gold nuggets in there yeah be able
to do yeah it's a good time to get
dumped start a company yeah
alright we're probably gonna have an
Elon Musk moment if we don't stop guys
thanks for coming in yeah oh thanks yeah
thank you
you